bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur ft france le gouvernement il
est sur tous les fronts avec des
annonces cette fois pour faire face à
une vague de pauvreté dont ils ne
mesurent pas forcément l'ampleur comme
l'a dit à l'instant florent guéguen que
l'on vient d'entendre est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec lui
je partage l'avis de florent guéguen
effectivement et je voudrais ajouter
tout de même que c'est vraiment une
politique absolu de la misère pour ce
qu'ils sont des gens d'une grande
précarité une pauvreté ce qui finalement
ont la tête déjà sous l'eau et
heureusement qu'il faut les aider c'est
central c'est absolument incroyable
mais ça veut dire qu'on a eu une
énumération des aides de la peur c'est
un véritable cauchemar social et
populaire mais par contre j'ai bien
écouté jean castex auprès ministre à
deux reprises d'ailleurs et il disait il
faut absolument se concentrer pour les
faire revenir dans le marché de l'emploi
mais que reste-t-il aujourd'hui du
marché de l'emploi nous savons toutes et
tous que nous venons de prendre un
tsunami nous allons prendre une qu'on
s'en prendre un tsunami économique sur
la tête et très sincèrement ça veut dire
que finalement quel poids ces mesures
vont avoir pour les gens qui sont
aujourd'hui dans une précarité qui sont
encore salarié mais qui sont sur le
point de se faire licencier
donc là et je voudrais ajouter quelque
chose il ya une phrase terrible de jean
castex qui avait absolument de terribles
m'a fait sursauter il dit jean castex
hamon au mieux du discours je ne peux
pas être un amant des gens qui
rentreront dans le chômage c'est un
désaveu absolument cinglant pour le
gouvernement qui dit par la boîte son
premier ministre finalement ceux qui
vont rentrer dans le chômage aujourd'hui
je ne pensais pas comment on va pouvoir
faire pour en sortir
est ce qu'on va dire ça aux salariés de
bridgestone de nokia des halles et toute
une série de marques aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont en train de licencier massivement
c'est extrêmement inquiétant dans le
sens où je le redis je pense que c'est
un désaveu cinglant du gouvernement et
c'est jean castex jeudi par mois qui
randonnée estiment qu'ils ne soient pas
mesure aujourd'hui de prévoir
d'anticiper les licenciements massifs
dom le chômage de masse qui va découler
de ces licenciements
alors il ya des mesures qui ont été
annoncées 1
des mesures notamment pour les jeunes de
l'aide au logement aussi avec notamment
1500 places d'hébergement
supplémentaires pour donner cet exemple
ça donne quand même l'impression que ce
sont des mesures un peu pansements alors
que le gouvernement l'a dit lui même
toute la semaine vous que cette pandémie
elle allait durer jusqu'à l'été 2021
donc c'est sur du long terme peut-être
qu'il faut envisager des mesures vous
avez vous avez tout dit samantha là tu
nous avais tu dis finalement il faut
absolument aujourd'hui c'est un point de
vue plus global c'est une politique de
fond beaucoup plus globale il faut
récupérer sa souveraineté économique à
moment donné rien industrialisés mais je
rappelle que c'est interdit par les
traités européens les traités bruxellois
il ya une urgence absolue a récupéré ce
connard regardez le cas de bridgestone
notamment ou bridgestone finalement on
va fermer son entreprise et vallée d
colisée en pologne en hongrie sans que
le gouvernement n'y puisse rien on
rappellera bruno le maire qui apprennent
toujours dessus sur et de plaider aux
autres vers des entreprises pardon pour
leur dire essayer de ne pas licencier et
c'est de ne pas appliquer la directive
travailleurs détachés
donc vous avez raison c'est un plan plus
massif là c'est une politique de
l'urgence absolue de gens tu le répètes
qui sont déjà la tête sous l'eau le rsa
164 1000 bénéficiaires de plus en 2020
des queues devant les secours populaire
ou les aides alimentaires on est
vraiment une pauvreté je crois qu'on
n'avait jamais vu en france depuis 30 40
ont même d'après guerre c'est absolument
mais je le redis il me jean castex
pardon il n'est pas encore président
jean castex mais il a dit je ne sais pas
je répète se fasse pour moi les
centrales c'est à dire qu'il ne prévoit
pas une ne peux pas anticiper il ne peut
pas apporter de solution aujourd'hui à
tous ces gens qui vont être au chômage
dans quelques temps je répète
bridgestone quand je vois des reportages
qui ont été faits sur ses salariés de
bridgestone qui sont lents famille
depuis père mère cousin et qui sont
aujourd'hui qui seront pleurs devant les
caméras parce qu'ils vont se faire virer
et qu'on leur dit que finalement il ne
peut pas prévenir un amant le chômage
comment vous comment voulez-vous que
selon aujourd'hui réagi sur place et
absolument effarant ce discours est
effarant donc les associations par
exemple réclament depuis des semaines
une hausse des minima sociaux et n'ont
pas obtenu gain de cause on a vu toute
la semaine
des mesures tous azimuts annoncées par
le gouvernement notamment en ce qui
concerne les personnels soignants là
encore emmanuel macron a visité un
hôpital de pontoise a pas d'annoncé en
tout cas concernant le renforcement des
effectifs et ce qui inquiète le plus les
personnels soignants là encore sur ces
associations qui viennent en aide aux
plus démunis
on voit que ces mesures elles sont quand
même beaucoup de timides
qu'est ce que cela révèle justement sur
la manière dont le gouvernement
aujourd'hui traite justement cette
pandémie au niveau national ben c'est si
la grande théorie c'est le grand
théorème le thuriféraire absolu vous
savez de la start-up d'etion com a vendu
il ya deux ans et demi au début la
flexibilité avec son lot de loi travail
sont un peu sa réforme mon chemin tout
l'assurance chômage par exemple ça jean
castex canada parle et on aurait pu
imaginer que cette loi
ce projet de loi sera abrogée et vous
l'avez dit sur les hôpitaux c'est pareil
emmanuel macron part de réorganisation
c'est pas une réorganisation qui font
les hôpitaux c'est un plat massif et je
rappelle toujours le fameux discours de
vernon rappelez vous où il avait annoncé
un grand plan pour l'hôpital donc
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron la politique
finalement la start up nation de la
flexibilisation est en train de
s'affronter de plein fouet à cette crise
absolument incroyable qu'on va prendre
élan incroyable c'est effarant tsé-tsé
tragique dramatique et emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui avec cette idée même de
start up nation
il est en train de ne pas pouvoir
répondre à la crise et dans son logiciel
idéologique et politique il ne peut pas
y répondre
finalement parce qu'il n'a pas envie
vous savez une nouvelle fois avec ce
néolibéralisme dont je passe souvent sur
l'a31 mondialisation il ne veut pas
monter faire monter dépense publique
mais bien au contraire les faire baisser
donc ça demanderait d'investir
massivement dans dans les services
publics notamment l'hôpital mais le
néolibéralisme complètement fou
d'emmanuel macron landes pêche de
logiquement de le faire merci à vous une
école à vidal je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de publication à deux putschs
médias